what do you know about altameyer give it  it fits things would break cars wouldn't  shut down that kind of thing  others have described seen things did he  show new things yes what kinds of things  I wouldn't know where to start we need  to know where he is  you'll have no clue what you're dealing  with did  that's going  what if fountain doesn't belong with us  you know  let's remark I know where they're going  he believes in something that people die  every day believe your intentions  you'll have to worry about me I'll  always worry about you I like where  anybody that's the deal it's okay  Emerson has become voiced see I'm kind  of washed - vomit sister tuna